se a efe una función diferenciable dos
veces una de estas gráficas representa
efe la otra a efe prima y la otra a efe
pi prima identifica cada función con su
respectiva gráfica así que te encargo
que pausa el vídeo e intentes encontrar
quién es
efe quién es efe prima y quiénes fbi
prima
ok es hora de trabajar juntos y bueno
hay un par de formas en las que podemos
resolverlo una forma de pensarlo es
decir si estas son gráficas de
polinomios entonces la función f debe de
ser un polinomio de grado mayor es decir
déjame ponerlo si ésta es efe y le
aplicamos la función derivada bueno pues
obtenemos a efe prima aquí le estamos
aplicando la derivada con respecto a x y
xi de nuevo tomas la derivada con
respecto a x obtienes fbi prima así que
cualquier grado que tenga tu polinomio
que represente la función f al derivar
lo va a obtener un polinomio de grado
menor de hecho de un grado menor en uno
menos la segunda derivada te quedaría un
polinomio de grado a un menor de hecho
en grado menor de dos menos que f
así que veamos si con esta idea podemos
identificar qué gráfica representa qué
función bueno una forma de pensarlo es
que los polinomios con grado mayor
tendrán una mayor cantidad de puntos
máximos o mínimos y parece que la vez es
la opción que tiene más máximos y
mínimos
la opción am sería el segundo lugar y la
opción c el tercer lugar entonces mi
hipótesis es que mi gráfica bem
representa la función f que me gráfica
amd representa mi función f prima y que
mi gráfica se representa la función fbi
prima así que esta es mi hipótesis vamos
a ver si en efecto tiene sentido y para
asegurarlo vamos a ver los puntos en
donde mi derivada es cero y ver la
derivada para confirmar que jeep tiene
el valor de 0 y también puedo ver las
tendencias así que veamos si ésta es efe
que es mi hipótesis inicial aquí tengo
una pendiente igual a 0 la pendiente de
mi recta tangente es igual a 0 y por acá
también tengo otra
de mi recta tangente que es igual a 0 y
por acá también y por último también por
acá así que veamos si esta fuera la
derivada entonces esta función debería
de ser igual a 0 en esos valores de x
porque la pendiente de la recta tangente
de esos valores es 0 así que esta es mi
función igual a 0 aquí perfecto también
aquí también aquí y también aquí bien
parece que coincide este 0 coincide con
este valor de x este con este valor de x
este otro con este otro valor de x y
este también con este así que me empiezo
a sentir más convencido de que esta es
la opción correcta y ahora veamos esta
función fbi prima es en efecto la
derivada de la función f prima bien pues
parece que tenemos un mínimo por aquí la
pendiente de mi recta tangente es igual
a cero por aquí parece que por aquí
también tenemos una pendiente igual a
cero y por aquí parece que también
tenemos una pendiente igual a cero así
que vamos a ver si para este valor de x
este valor de x y este valor de x la
función f mi prima es igual a 0 y
observan podemos ver que en efecto esta
función toma el valor de 0 justo aquí y
aquí y aquí en esos mismos valores de x
así que basándonos en lo que digo me
siento bastante convencido y aún cuando
tuviera prisa
estoy seguro de que identifique bien
estas gráficas con sus respectivas
funciones pero también podemos ver las
tendencias con calma
por ejemplo déjame mostrarte una
tendencia al principio la pendiente está
decreciendo por aquí observa es decir la
pendiente se vuelve cada vez más
negativa y puedes ver que entre este
punto y este de aquí en efecto la
función se ve cada vez más negativa y
después por acá la pendiente empieza a
volverse cada vez más positiva hasta
llegar a este punto y lo mismo pasa con
la tendencia tiende a ser consistente
observa pasa lo mismo
así que una forma de encontrar la
respuesta era ver las tendencias y ver
qué le pasaba a la gráfica u otra forma
era verlo
máximos y los mínimos ha dicho otra
manera donde tienes rectas tangentes
horizontales es decir donde la pendiente
de la recta tangente es 0 y comprobarlo
con la función derivada estas dos
opciones son las formas más fáciles para
hacer esta identificación nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo